بغض النظر عن عمرك، فإن الاعتناء
بعقلك أمر بالغ الأهمية للصحة العامة،
فالتدهور المعرفي ليس أمرًا حتميًا مع
تقدمك في العمر، وفي الواقع هناك أشياء
يمكنك القيام بها للحفاظ على صحة دماغك مع
تقدمك في السن، يقول تقرير جديد لـ AARP إن هناك
ست طرق للمساعدة  حماية دماغك،
الحصول على نوم جيد، إدارة التوتر، البقاء نشيطًا،
ما هو جيد لجسمك، مفيد لعقلك،
يفكر الناس في
ممارسة التمارين الرياضية لعضلاتهم، لكن
عقلك مثل ذلك تمامًا، عليك أن
تبقيه منشغلًا ويتحرك، وتناول الطعام
الصحي، وكن اجتماعيًا، وتفاعل
عقلك.  يمكن أن يساعد أيضًا في الحفاظ على صحته، لكن
المنظمة تقول إن الحفاظ على
صحة الدماغ أسهل بالنسبة للبعض من الآخرين. إذا
كنت تعيش في مجتمع تمثل فيه السلامة
مشكلة أو ليس لديك أرصفة،
فمن الصعب ممارسة
الوصول إلى أماكن مثل المتنزهات
والترفيه التي تساعدك  كن اجتماعيًا ولكن إذا
لم تكن لديك هذه الفرص أو إذا
كنت محرومًا اقتصاديًا، فمن
الصعب جدًا عليك أن تقول فقط دعنا
نخرج ونمارس الرياضة إذا كنت تعمل في
وظيفتين أو ثلاث وظائف، يقول التقرير أن
التكنولوجيا والمنصات مثل
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي  يمكن أن يساعد في نشر الوعي حول
أهمية الحفاظ على ذكاء الدماغ إذا كان
أصحاب العمل ومقدمو الرعاية الصحية
يتحدثون عن صحة الدماغ
ويجعلونك أكثر وعيًا
وتذكرًا أن هناك أشياء
يمكنك القيام بها، فإنه يسهل عليك
الحفاظ عليها من أجل الصحة.  أنا أندي
جايثر
[موسيقى]